el ministro de asuntos exteriores ruso
serguéi lávrov ya está en turquía donde
mañana se encontrará con su homólogo
turco mevlüt cavusoglu para abordar la
cuestión del bloqueo marítimo en los
puertos del mar negro de ucrania para
intentar liberar el trigo que espera en
el puerto de odessa rusia se muestra
dispuesta a que el puerto sea vaciado de
trigo y que ucrania se siga vendiendo su
ruso su trigo recordemos que rusia y
ucrania son los dos grandes países del
mundo exportadores de trigo y sin este
trigo ahora mismo mercado mundial está
en una absoluta desesperación en una
crisis tanto humanitaria como
alimenticia encierra rusia se mostró
dispuesta a liberar ya permitir que a
ucrania sigue a comerciando con su trigo
a cambio de que ucrania termine su costa
marítima ahora mismo me nada ante la
posible invasión marítima rusa algo que
de momento un gran no se muestra muy
dispuesta a hacer precisamente por el
miedo a que rusia utilice este desminado
para intentar una invasión marítima como
ya hizo el febrero la invasión terrestre
turquía sentándome dar entre estos dos
países para hacer que el trigo crea nos
llegue primero a estambul desde aquí se
ha distribuido por todo el mundo a
través
de los estrechos del bósforo y los
dardanelos además turquía y rusia
hablarán mañana sobre el conflicto sirio
donde turquía está intentando amenazar
en una nueva ofensiva militar contra el
norte de ese país rusia tiene efectivos
militares en la zona y no muestra no se
muestra muy encontrada que turquía
realice una nueva operación militar
contra las milicias kurdas del norte de
siria